ding-ding-ding thinking back to the
genital podcast singing in lap thank you
guys yeah you no wonder for so long yeah
it's [ __ ] up pointing at me right
people really tweeting at me after the
whole jacksFilms things they were like
here is a [ __ ] crazy person only a
self-absorbed maniac names and like a
dog after themselves and I was like no
no no no no and that I use with you have
his work good effort though he imagines
like me naming my dog Maury her me name
are dark Julianne no so Lomita premier
Julianne dream tweet to e6 I would like
to have a son but you name like Julian
the second Julius both look junior I
I think that's weird I mean not weird I
just I could never ever in a million
years see myself even thinking of doing
that is that so like a popular thing
happens
I know people whose fathers are their
same names man yes still yeah I mean I'm
not I'm not hating on it I just I could
never I could never be in that mind
frame of like I'm so deeply invested in
leaving a legacy that I'm literally
renaming my son the same name I have
like I don't seems kind of wild seems a
little weird
seems a little weird just Oh mad about
it
now doesn't used to be a weird thing
where'd you get that bit I'm a little of
glass of wine you know nice having a big
old mug of GF beer right here this
[ __ ] cartoonishly big thing it's a
big mug big mug well we have a nice
little part to for you this this week
can you guess what Cherie now you're
you're like beard rubbing up against is
that beard a long oh you did not
that's the sound of my beard don't be
nasty said rolled on one of the podcasts
is don't be nasty no on a resume is be
nasty ol be nasty
mmm-hmm
to two liters I'm going to finish that
whole beer by the end of this podcast
that is a certified guarantee Tennessee
I don't you can go to gingerly pause
calm and Keynes you what what what what
happened blackout no are we talking okay
what are we doing doing alright we're
doing um part two of honest company
slogans yeah any sponsors hood yeah we
got some sponsors are you Lana oh okay
okay Jenna so eager and again to these
sponsor she's like she's like petrified
where the segue is gonna come from on
the heels of last week well when is that
segue coming well come Julie oh come on
it's Lee oh come okay it's gonna come in
hot blazing hot don't want it - oh it's
coming in hot
what is it not Cheetos its flaming hot
here later not tuna I feel like so it
should make sleeves and hot cheetos
blaze and they spell cheetos with zeros
instead of oh so they don't get trouble
with copyright okay
ch3 3 t 0s blazin blazin I'm sorry about
that so basically what we do here is we
before we sat down here we came up
individually with about 15 or so maybe
you have more than me
companies or brands and we wrote honest
slogans so if the slogans weren't made
for marketing purposes that they were
made based on like real life and actual
feedback of customers aka us this is
what the slogans for these companies
would be we tried
make them funny although I don't think
mine are very funny okay but we can
discuss and see if we agree and you guys
should have a good time of it yes it's
fun I don't on the front I need my phone
and I don't have it he's not good boy
here is it you know what you know you
don't need it I need it why well so for
later I needed but whatever
no first one okay all right are you
going first I wanted to go first
all right see this table is all like tip
your mic is like perfectly like this and
mine is just straight into my face
no boy okay another week okay I'm
complaining about ourselves
alright mounds are you ready yeah
who looks lucky to mouth this is the
lady's candy forever which I got great
selling almond joy and took out one
element from it mount who was it who was
it watch this we were not on that's
funny that's funny because mounds of you
think about it is just a shape it's just
a shape it's a mess like maybe a candy
bar and calling it whole oh I like like
why can't eat that anymore they have
milk chocolate on them but like I used
to language enough it's just coca and
chocolate good it's really good but like
everybody seems to prefer almond joy
because there's like a little crunch in
there a little texture a little bit
lighten it I like mouths better but
really no one eats them yeah a
shockingly low number of people eat my
own everybody doing we're not backing
this up with any actual information yeah
I was never been cake candy bar guy
growing up candy bar boy what was your
preferred cam I love Halloween and you
got candy what were you like yes I was a
kid I love Kit Kats
that's a candy bar yeah yeah I wasn't a
big candy bar boy that means I didn't
have a lot of candy bars that I ate
there was a few one was
Katz the other was crunch all kids are
like that no no no I was different I'm
different than my favorite candy bar I
can't claim to not be a candy bar boy
while having a favorite kid are like
most kids take a I'm a different type of
kid mm-hmm okay so just leave me out of
it okay we will do it okay talk I gotta
get a good one to start with why because
I was good man just give us what you got
get postmates come outside please we're
20 minutes away I was bitter rightly
propose that I didn't but it was like
text to you we don't have it did you
send them a picture wait yes we do
that's literally half of our post Nate's
exchanges oh I can't find it and then
you send the picture order you say
please ask for help and then they're
like okay I found it yeah you want
something else or would you like to
cancer or like Madonna no no no no like
I feel like we leave such because a lot
of the stuff that we post me if it's
firmly a grocery store is it some pretty
hard to find sometimes like gluten for
your vegan stuff it's not like super
easy like someone wouldn't know it and
let's hear familiar with those foods so
I always like write a description about
where to find it like what I listen like
you know that kind of thing and like
describe what it is like oh it's a vegan
meat substitute that looks like ground
beef it's in a baggie to the natural
food section of the freezer like then
they get very like they don't have it
like [ __ ] text me a picture of the
frozen food aisle and I'm like is right
there you saw this but not really I
ordered recently I ordered beyond beef
it's like a plant-based like ground beef
substitute and it comes to this like red
bag and I ordered it and they text back
here I'll then have it and I literally
before I order the post Nate I called
that store I was like do you have this
specific item narrowed yes we do so
that's why we post night so I was like
could you maybe ask for help like I just
confirmed on the phone that they had and
he was like yeah they said they don't
have it I was like could you maybe send
me a picture of what they do have and he
sends me a picture and in the corner of
the picture that's it it's like in the
picture he literally send me a picture
with the item in it saying
dude right there oh so clips
solutely I bet you wish you were
sunburned and you had a mean friend
because this ain't going to be a
five-star I give everybody five star
unless they did something like blatantly
wrong
I give like 95% of people five stars if
they're just an hour and a half or two
hours when I know it doesn't take that
long from like what were you doing with
my time
all right I go and you ready there we go
feet like the bug spray deep mm-hmm what
what do you say deep do I want some
teeth you ever goes camping I was like
here spread your legs with deep you're
like wait what what I realize was deep
why would you call rock deep I don't
understand that name I've never actually
heard I've never actually heard of it
being called deep not bug spray but deep
because no DEET feet yeah exactly
feet feet with the teeth I actually have
heard of that but I've never heard of
anyone used that as the name of the
product
hey you want some CIL hours if it bugs
friend some default deep what deep deep
deep it's just like a conversation
confuse er mm-hmm deep what that's so
slow give you real market we have to
roll is our world market to vision yes
by better world market we have chairs
and snacks but don't [ __ ] sit in the
chairs or taste of snacks really you
can't sit in the chair
no I'm gonna yell it like five times
yeah yeah they're all so comfortable to
sing or they're on display you're not
supposed to touch up and then there's
like a whole aisle of snacks I have
taken notes from Costco
gift some snacks for free make little
stand with checkered tablecloth muscle
feel welcome make you feel like summer I
have world market yo we low-key also a
liquor store they're like five different
stores hmm like liquor stores they're
like candle and and candle stores player
dad furniture and then food
that's about it for Amazon are you sure
you don't also want this Oh brutal so
[ __ ] real though every time you buy
something it's like customers also
bought and went off [ __ ] I like that and
it's always really like that well want
that and the thing is is like you know
especially if you're a Prime membership
you're looking at a Prime membership
hold it right here
ah please you're like I get free like a
new day sometimes one day shipping okay
I get free shipping on this package
might as well throw on a little add-on
that's diddly just just oh thank you
just spank a little bit oh my god that
is a wine glass marbles I'm touching the
mic anyway that's it okay do you want me
to go you know I want to finish talking
about spanking items into the cart mm mm
so the carts are here okay you know it's
about a jet off in your house 24-hour up
here like lightning fast you just get on
in there join the club
okay there's going to be nice big bubble
of plastic that protects you from
careless mailmen throwing the Box around
you're safe in here you're going to see
Julian what Dad somewhere else in there
Sam ago Amazon so you start please tell
them okay I'll tell you I smell it
exclamation point ever said pound sign
hey Astrid okay it was on and then the
commercial was like Amazon not to be
confused
like when when you say something sassy
or you're like no you did it like this
then that's a different that's like very
different that's like TTT k this is
recomendation betrayed his tongue and
the top of the mouth yeah and then this
one is like girl no you did I've never
heard the cracking sound from that girl
in that girl situation that's the thing
that's but not to be confused because
Amazon is the only one that has Amazon
please imagine someone touch that Amina
hey what if we are tagged on it is
literally just as [ __ ] really
annoying noise Amazon would you like to
be up what's going on with you we're
recording
wait when he growls will you do a voice
again yeah yeah I wanted to return it no
you check there Amy check out how
they're made noise another phone even
your own your phone oh okay
you don't get to just do it so it sounds
terrifying I'm terrified of my platform
we're good all right are you ready for
my next one yeah Marvel you ready to
shut up sorry got out of line I'm sorry
hi I'm shy Coppertone sunscreen yeah we
got kiddie porn on our bottle for years
since like 1975 our bottles in Chinese
everybody that's a that's a kid but we
got a baby blot on here maybe us aren't
any porn that's why pizza Jill took a
good peaceful kid but what okay debate
time comics if I bring up a looking but
personally I feel
Oh Fox out yeah yeah personally I think
if you're the parents thank you but it's
your kid yeah you're changing the
diapers this kid but but on a bottle of
not your kid what kid but is this
come get your kid but it's not your
nails runner or a child that you're
caring for or like your friend your
neighbor or someone this is like maybe
barely connected to you yeah I think are
just thinking generally like your little
neighbor's running around with the kid
busts out they've got run around the
sprinklers and [ __ ] that's fine how are
you kid
what I got a do something it's when
you're advertising a kid but I feel like
it's not that - totally - but mmm all
right today we got a high of 95 there's
going to be some kid but running around
the street make sure you turn on your
sprinklers for the kid but they're going
to be running around their bathing suits
and the Coppertone
I used to see you through my bathing
suit in those into the street I will
stand over the sprinkler having like go
up in my visit and pee down I was like
hell yeah [ __ ] with me you know every
like Valentine's Day I try to find words
and I can express why I love you I think
you just summed it up in one sentence
what when I was a kid I peed through my
bathing suits in the sprinkler into the
spring better yeah yeah but you ever
have set up a sprinkler and then you
just go sort of like sit on it straddle
it no like not even that like oh you did
everything you in your you're like legs
and body because everywhere around it's
just like something that kids do you
feel like it's like stepping on it with
your body yeah and then um yeah I feel
like oh this is a great time just to pee
real quick I used to pee in the lake
because everyone thinks I'm a me too but
everyone thinks I'm just sitting on the
sprinkler but now I'm just I'm over here
tinkling a good
forget Mo's this is the worst part
though is P bits are flying every bit T
this like like pee little bits of tea
your are flying everywhere around you
it's like you're being surrounded by a
force field of pee well it's good for
your skin
like I said in one of the podcast before
it's like getting really Mershon of all
oh my god do not call me a wonderful
person does not call me away in like
high end foot cream and stuff urea is
like usually one of the top three
ingredients which is just [ __ ] urine
basically and like I was on a diving
team and you we would wear flip-flops in
the shower and stuff obviously because
you're in by the pool because you'll get
planters worth like all over the bottom
of your feet if you get in the shower
and pee on your feet you will never get
like planners or scrum walking around
pool like that so real thing you know
and it's not cuz you nasty it's because
you just in that water where it just is
what it it's good I just thought a
situation where someone's he's on his
friends foot because you get stung you
by something like a like a jellyfish
doesn't really wake that little what no
it's just like a lot of thought of
someone being on a friend's foot I would
say word I'd be on I hope you'll need me
to I think you'd be way too excited to
pee on me as well oh whoa okay oh man
recording y'all not an outfit is my
impression of Julian if a jellyfish
stung me and he deemed it worthy of
peeing on it I got this played out laid
out laid out well you're welcome I'm
just trying to help okay
I don't want you to have an infected
sting in your leg somebody's well but
your nipping Lisa Oh nip it in the bud
all weekend all right well you get aa
face book got you that's one view do the
thing where you made a circle if you
think like you're going to punch me yeah
because if you glance at over one second
is a view oh my god choco kyun like that
got you this one view I counted it as to
it I told that advertisers it's one view
scroll through your feet see it one beer
oh my god and you wonder why views or
someone plated on Facebook history well
I hear like 50 50 from people they're
like nah do those views are legit and
like yeah but I know a lot of a Martin
legit because I'm the person scrolling
through Facebook sometimes where you see
they just start playing there's no sound
and I know it counted as a view yeah I'm
scrolling past it I went back and there
was literally one more video and then I
went back together there was one
I'd like to use our legit but they're
not watching it yeah yes somebody who
saw it they'd be using this anyway
someone views it as a glance at everyone
I can easily regret and then get plot
yeah I think we needed a more clear
definition of view yeah okay all right I
have adidas Originals all the cool
Street where you want not available
anywhere near you here have some
athletic wear sleeve oh god what
happened
it didn't really such cool like Street
wear it like half of my favorite clothes
are all of their like street wear you
know I don't know what happened to that
store because there was one couple years
ago I'm in Melbourne yeah it's a Melrose
store in near Hollywood and we went
there a couple years ago eighty-five for
us to get in there like a trip to go
there yeah but like years ago they a
like and in this this was like right
when the adidas hype train was kind of
you know getting going the tutu is
starting to having Easy's we're just
beginning and [ __ ] but you could find so
many cool items there shoes you got so
many cool jumpsuit like the shirts too
short the hats the jacket everything
they were sucking dove and it was the
only place you get it was like the
adidas Originals store and now we go and
it's like the [ __ ] the the [ __ ]
clearance aisle it's like no one wants
this [ __ ] so we're just putting in the
store it's ridiculous it sucks man
it really went from like good to bad
well especially since the when we went
to Japan yeah one time which I wish was
all the time no mazing but we went we
made it a point to go that Adidas store
in Japan
yes they had like an enormous selection
of the street where it's like they
ensure that we don't carry any more well
yes or never half or you can only find
online or never find online there looks
like at least the Japanese Adidas store
understands like that's a big part of
what people want yes they have a huge
selection like what makes you think the
American people don't want this [ __ ]
adidas treat wear please give it to us
what the [ __ ]
dad well I think Japanese 3 wear has
been ahead of the curve for a long time
and even just Japanese like a pair like
sports apparel like remember when I told
you I was dying for that titanium
catcher's mask yeah
I learned about Mikey JP which is the
Japan website for Nike and they had it
like like anyone to Japan and could just
buy it and this is something that was
nowhere think about Italian Greyhound
closed that [ __ ] store where you
bought me those turtle rice permit for a
TIG works I do not know if they like our
selling to America or not at this point
but it's like as far as I could tell is
one designer like the most incredible
impeccable amazing clothes for Italian
Greyhounds specifically like turn on
items are certainly only sold in Japan
Julianne like jump through hoops and
[ __ ] are you know back and forth with
them this is when I first started dating
you and I was like I need a cake to
knock this out of the park but that
fashion like [ __ ] me up please sell in
America please we walk whole stuff yeah
please give us your Italian Greyhound
clothes yeah and like the [ __ ] he has is
soft
- it's like incredible material yeah but
it's not quite micro little fabric
because if it was Michael brother fabric
it would be sold right any of these and
it is not okay me and these is just for
you guys
and you know speaking of me and these
you guys can go Jane calm right now if
I'm the best pair of underwear in the
world number sign and but okay so Jesus
so every month they have new designs it
alternate feel good on these for when
you want to feel naked cannot be naked
think about that you feel naked but you
are not naked
it's appropriate but it feels in a
perfect that's me I use for you micro
model fabric is three times softer than
cotton I personally have a drawer in my
closet currently and happily overflowing
with manatees because they send you a
pair every month or you can just go buy
one pair it's really awesome
okay this sustainably sourced micro
model fabric okay and like I said the
new designs everyone they have a [ __ ]
pair of underwear with pizza on it okay
what more do you want if they in a
purchase soft other work with PETA auto
play right now wait hold on the designs
that you get you can also buy and then
so if you have a significant order you
guys can wear MAGIX is the same on D
it's been abused I have another problem
also cook you mentioned a minute I think
the underwear looks a lot a lot better
on your button it doesn't mine that's
just my opinion also I'm not a person
who stares in the mirror of my own
buttons there's damn that looks good
no it's dinner I think my butt getting
big I think my bucket big we got getting
hot in here so take up earlier boy you
sit up Julian guys right now me and ease
up soda by the way agnya days is one of
the og Jenna Julian podcast sponsors and
their family to FAA even recently
sponsored a Twitter stream and we're
going to be doing more with them on
Twitch support them they are great
people
and an amazing product owner you have to
tell you more guys right now they're
offering you 20% off your first pair and
free shipping when you go to meet undies
comm / Jimmy Julian that's em e undies
comm / Jenner Julian's start wearing the
best underwear of your life and look
[ __ ] goddamn good doing it
goddamn good oh you don't okay did you
mess with the focus and you've got alone
with hey what are you doing right now
we're probably out of foam it's fine hey
Mikey what what time's it [ __ ] I can't
tell cuz I on my movement watch god yeah
yeah high-quality minimalist product in
a movement watch it doesn't break the
bank okay as you're looking at watches
in department sources I know I do you
walk through departments or children is
watch on tape maybe I'll try this on you
neglecting the price tag you finally end
up doing it it's $500 you don't have to
kind of catch that who would spend on
kind of a watch it's stupid movement
watch has the classic minimalist quality
designs for you at affordable prices
okay they've sold over 1 million watches
in 160 countries mine is actually
another room show the [ __ ] rabbit
here it's it's really really [ __ ]
nice piece kind with a white black on
black she is black like I have a white
face and a brown band and it's so nice
to the board it's like every wedding
I've been to and it's light it's light
is like doesn't wait on your wrist it
doesn't make you all like uncomfortable
and sweaty and it dresses up whatever
you're wearing like it is such a quality
and cool-looking design for someone
who's like loved like
accessories and like trying to find cool
menswear and the accessory aisle for a
long time movement has been incredible
because it's affordable and it looks
like it's not affordable you know
basically right now guys you can step up
your watch and get 15% off and free
shipping with free returns they're going
to nvm t.com /jj that's nvm t.com /jj
get that nice discount look through
their calendar watches you will not be
disappointed I promise okay I was just
thinking about this wasn't have anything
to do with movement Watchers but I was
thinking about something that looks nice
at an affordable price and they made me
think about the Super Deluxe that I
showed you tabasco sweet hahahaha we're
watching his channel he's basically
theories called cheese curls so he
basically takes like you know whatever
it's a DIY Channel for making knock-off
designer what I love about it walking
amazed i favorite part about it is it
mocks like the height beast culture yeah
like supreme and like cheese bells only
really dumb [ __ ] that people spend money
on says the guy was a supreme hat I
didn't buy it was a gift but it's very
funny like he recreated a Gucci belt
with the red and the like alright next
next step my family dude it's only funny
be here hey go line his name Tabasco
sweet revenge of essence yeah but with a
kt8 bees s yeah he's very ki kind of
just a natural volume
yeah it's not though I don't know
anything about Super Deluxe what they
post you know stuff every it feels like
a BuzzFeed is it my turn your turn I
have one to go with my last one
go ahead adidas by Rita Ora
I thought of Rita Ora was a french fry
or some [ __ ] I'm just kidding that's not
mine that is one of my favorite tweets
of all time that I read many years ago
that made me [ __ ] laugh for probably
six years I don't know JK
Rita Ora barely works she just cute for
a living
did you write that oh the tea is hot
today when I said come for real though
like this is no shade to read or I think
she's fine I like
I like her voice I like when she makes
music but it does feel a lot like every
once in a while should sprinkle a song
your way and then you're like alright I
guess we'll uh we'll just see you around
we'll see you around but like that's
that's about it
is that shape um
it's tricky no no no just a little bit
darker in here that's a little bit I got
I have nothing to do if I'm wrong no
because I'm not a baby
Robert is compared to tender boy I don't
know who what Reed or doesn't doesn't do
sorry I love you but I don't have no
impossible
I don't maybe she does look cute for a
living it's not that that's the joke is
that like I feel like you see tabloid
pictures of her and stuff like going
around and hanging out people and like
doing stuff but then creatures outside
shell sprinkle a song at you it's never
like an album and then she'll like so
she see me at places and be an award
show she's playing this game it's like
how I did in school eat in a bottle
where I'm right you do the minimum
amount of work then you're at the right
place at the right time and you're
you're great dude yeah I read or as I
see yeah not shade but like we don't
have for your compliment like she knows
what the [ __ ] is it with acting on
effort read or barely works but she's
you for a living and also you're calling
her cute this is not shade this is the
income and I did like some of her read
or adidas Originals
I didn't is my changing men's work cuz
I'm waiting for read or to come out with
menswear line up french fries Rita or Oh
better for the masculine of aura should
I leave well Travis think Rogers that
was a snake whoa
shale gas some of our locations have
normal price gas some
yo shade yeah I don't really pay where
do we go - L see I only know that it cuz
I grew up in an area where like near
Santa Monica there was this one [ __ ]
Shell gas station
then had like a dollar on top of every
other guy or nerve the nerve right but
then you go out of town in the shell
normal and you're like wait why I don't
get it why is one of them for the
convenience of the location oh but I
know exactly what you're saying cause I
lives in Santa Monica I know exactly the
gas station you're talking about because
you drive past like two or three six and
well sure that's shell right you're
talking I don't know but you drive past
like two or three and you're like
alright those are the same and then that
one you're like what the [ __ ] when I
stop there good you got some air you
know someone Oh her what else you got
boy alright I got a wet Seal oh wow this
is she oh she it fell apart that's T no
it's not it is your your officers murder
it's not T because if you buy your shirt
for like four dollars it's okay that
puzzles are true then you can like
repurpose it as like a kitchen hacks but
that was like you know when I was in
college and you're buying stuff like
alright it was a top like even a nice
top you can wear out is like $12 it's
okay if I spill my beer all over this
and like my friend rips it while we're
dancing because I spent spent $12 on if
you get like a lot of wear out of it
that was like a really good deal
certainly me but if something happens to
it like it's not a bad thing yeah I
bought up a 12 and that's an expensive
one you buy $7 shirt there
$4 shirt there high end over there yeah
no they get more expensive than that but
still yeah it's like it is disposable
clothes almost yeah I understand that I
kind of feel like it's some pieces of
hmmm her like that yeah like cute oh my
gosh every dollar it falls apart zambian
oil yeah and like free go then you spend
like you know then you get like nitro
for your birthday or whatever like you
got me a nice shirt of everything and
I've taken really good care of those
shorts because I like they're nice and I
love but it's already like spilled juice
with pulp but I on
like a nation I'm sure everything $10 I
work a couple times maybe I'll wear it
with stating our children is this right
here is wife belongings cause suffering
because if you have nice things
then all you do is think about those
things and ruining those things and what
would you do something happened to those
nice things so the solution is to not
have nice things or really a lot of
things at all so you don't get attached
to them at all if everything's fine
I am a Middle East I don't have any
belongings it's supposed to be like this
I am a minimalist I have no belonging
good for you good all right
ready for mime yeah I got one we go
along sort of with my last one though
that I think you'll appreciate don't
snap your notebooks brah Amazon Chevron
we really tried but we couldn't get the
rights to carve the movie I never seen
cars a movie at that though no they're
whole [ __ ] thing is like cars with
eyes and like talking cars but it's like
a shitty ripoff with cards already I
guess I've never seen that Chevron was
tech on your nursing those Aspen oh wow
[ __ ] me right okay well I had forever 21
more like forever shrinking the men's
section into a tinier and tinier corner
and toes what are we gone they deleted
amends session I don't know forever 21
yeah that's I kill one no the time is
anymore
well okay you mean that I understand but
like in terms of clothes that will fit
you and that you can wear it's like
every time Julian goes up the escalator
he's just like well [ __ ] why did I think
it used to be a whole like half of the
upper Phelan school and then they
cornered it to is one corner and then
they turn that corner into like a unisex
like there's not even Enzo anymore yes
feels like just headbands and accessory
doesn't prettier than jewelry and you're
like whatever dude [ __ ] me whatever dude
checked it I'll just get my underwear it
means I like forever tell you
yeah I did I used to then they forgot
about me people I guess that's what you
got going on the next page
hmm damn subway eat fresh or eat here yo
you're a shady day yeah i'ma say today
okay sorry talk about it surprised even
I ate me like I hated subway I'm so
sorry
subway because I know there I have
plenty of friends that prefer that they
like they love subway same reason people
prefer like McDonald's burger to like a
high end hamburger it's like the
processed foods have that like addictive
taste yet no I get it but like it was
never for me yeah it's almost ironic
that their slogan is heat rash that way
eat fish yeah anyway
isn't there a YouTube video that I think
you look up if you haven't for like how
the process like they don't even cut the
the Peter cheese like in the house it's
sent to them like rice old and I stand
like nasty it's pretty gross it's very
good it is okay if you put your hand
over the grass and touched me it would
be cleaner than if you didn't you nasty
alright I got American spirit cigarettes
I'm in only smoke when I drink kind of
person Bluff let her there and sad for
you but if you think these things are
gluten free
I always paying way too much for my
coffee I never lose arguments because I
literally refuse valid points I'm
actually rather annoying
I have an add-on to that why don't I
sell these are hopeless I've resorted
you will say American spirits are like
healthy cigarettes like pure and like
natural I mean there's only a couple
people to me when I see them smoking
American spirits I'm like yeah you're
still a cool person like I [ __ ] you
because I know the person who shall be
my elder that's when people say the
things that it's not it's like it's it's
just too much sometimes when other
people are just like
those people that are like they work out
non-stop and definitely close pictures
of their brown rice on the Instagram
saying [ __ ] fit meals the [ __ ] okay
you just have a vendetta with brown rice
not start I'm talking about like it's a
the people a bit like work out a bunch
to just walk over to Pinkberry and then
they're like big orange I'm like large
with extra marshmallows yes but then
they're the ones to tell you that it was
frozen yogurt and you know it's like
some [ __ ] hip I can't we just have
no calories
yeah it's like I can't believe I'm
talking a cigarette but it's like it's
not even a real so it's better for you I
know it's like the cop-out cigarette
it's like people who drink diet talk
diet coke and are really convinced that
it's better for you okay
still drinking a cold beverage with like
better literal [ __ ] chemicals in it
better but also at the same time
horribly worse
well it's better which way do you wanna
die that's an American spirit it's gonna
not make you diver bad baby but you know
that's another thing that we don't even
own a car yeah like American spirit
might have less chemicals than it was
like American spirit which way you
wanted I passed this wagon right there
I'm very constricted which way you wanna
die oh that's [ __ ] up alone and
talking to myself like an [ __ ]
goddamn American spirit okay
I'm just kidding sort of not good um my
turn
good Archaea you can't pronounce it or
build it whoa like you pronounce like he
is oh yeah the only thing I can
pronounce at IKEA are one two three this
season snippy chops off to Nyssa dancing
and if you have a disease or smelly's in
your house I love you I want to come sit
on those misses and smoothies otherwise
our literal names of furniture from Ikea
yeah their chairs
and uh but you know it's like a secret
code II might have is my best friend you
know it's caught it they didn't really
this is only get a tattoo someday Jenna
might not leave and
you can do what you want your body boy
all right
greenies actual crack for dark yep
actual like I think the dogs are
addicted to greenie they behave
differently with the Greenies out than
they do anytime with anything it's crazy
that you know I feel like you should
adopt that slogan because it's going to
targeting y'all upset they can't read
but you are like now you can gather the
info you're like oh I didn't crack for
dog doing okay we did it yeah I don't
you kids are going to attend good I'm
not in the most literal person like in a
Petco be like I'm looking for a pipe for
my greenies they're crack for dog you
see the psychic-type
a very literal de a dog owner comes in
pairs wait correctamundo
mm I got more than you oh yeah I got a
couple I only have a few left Michael
Kors what's up with all these poopy
pants that's white a literal Michael
Kors nice I like it uh supreme you guys
are dumb give us your money
yes oh my god people are dumb
give us your money I gotta go Kim
Kardashian beauty kylie need a lot of
money so i figured i could probably make
more but I won't
Oh mommy or maybe Donnie and I want
those catty Lucas okay branding on ya
Kylie Sawyer I mean I've heard mixed
reviews about Kim Kardashian's beauty I
have not tried it and you know it took
me like forever to get Kylie lip kit I
got that kind of [ __ ] it took me forever
I actually my only ones that I have were
like gifts from people that gave me
because there are records now you've won
yeah and now you finally have the Kylie
lip kit enjoy girl um but I have heard
some pretty mixed things about the Kim
Kardashian beauty but she's already
rolling out like more [ __ ] looks like
now I'll even rated an Irish model for
them to do this is that what I know
Littleton
nothing about makeup you know that but
what I can appreciate about tighly and
the way she's marketed her lips is we're
not here to talk [ __ ] about hi I'm
literally just praising her
oh praise it I what I can appreciate is
that she's clearly made a product that
stands apart from the rest in its genre
right it's a lip kit but it's not just
oh look it's a kind of looked like you
hear that name it has a buzz to it and
it's been created by this branding that
she started with I mean at least from
what I see this is someone speaking on
the outs of the makeup or like I don't
know [ __ ] about makeup but what I've
seen it's like these are the easy to
make up no pun intended I know they're
in the same [ __ ] family or whatever
but she gets over snapchat and she
[ __ ] shows every single thing and I'm
like oh this is interesting right I can
see what all these things look like now
it's interesting I think it's i think
props yeah I mean a lot of people do
that in the beauty community thank you
darling I see what you're right
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm literally
speaking out my ass all right I got one
more in the wing the light ears so that
we can even these eggs I get a kind of a
demon voice real quick come our demon
voice yeah okay one second there you go
quick you just Mayo so we are going to
[ __ ] destroy you
oh my god okay can we give a little
background here cuz that made no sense
to anyone is one of my like favorite
conspiracy theories ever and it came up
to be true yeah it was like I think at
first saw only toy or moments or
something it was like there's a wild
conspiracy theory going around to see
the egg industry like as a whole was
trying to destroy the male brand just
mail which is a vegan mayonnaise brand
gradually no eggs well yeah they don't
have any eggs - so dairy um and like
these egg executives were like trying to
take them down
yeah because one of the main ways that
they've made a lot of money was by
having eggs and Minnie's like as an
ingredient I had an another way on the
mayonnaise market use where eggs did you
do that yes there is what your color
source of like we can make money from
yeah and then I guess apparently I don't
remember exactly I went down but like
the emails came
like maybe really were like actively
sabotaging this one minis brand we're
not letting a man hiding in [ __ ] right
[ __ ] up crazy eggs we see you just
mail and we are going to [ __ ] destroy
the supporter look on my favorite those
Labor's favorite because it sounded so
ridiculous yeah alright my last one
after that before I just tell them what
Jared came in Turkey this boy eat and
Jared boy and he's melted she's ah DHL
this package isn't from the United
States it's just like international
packages a bit
yes something funny paralyzed to be
funny a FedEx ding-dong-ditch
how many times you had a FedEx package
two on the way and you're waiting
waiting in the nearly go E and it's just
in my place they go get a sip of water
you come back and there's a note on your
door and you're like how the [ __ ] did
they get that there yeah yeah
it wouldn't be easier to just deliver it
you have to come back yeah you would
think all right I got a Buick plus we
keep definitely trying to rebrand please
just buy our card if you can figure out
what logo we have now with Furillo
they have reread it so many times that
Trader Joe's Hawaiian shirts are dope if
you wear them all day every day
oh here you I feel like a better slogan
for trader Joseph's we got a lot of
snacks not a lot of other [ __ ] you look
yeah that's way better definitely way
better uh Invisalign invisible braces
except for all these invisible braces we
done cemented TT do you know how [ __ ]
InDesign work so you know how they
market it at this as it's like clear
retainer that you just like pop in your
honor and then they give you know they
literally they call the buttons I'm
sorry but they're just round clear
braces that they put on different teeth
in your mouth animate unlikely and
generous conversation I only thought our
business well and then they stay healthy
so then you put the retainer and it
clicks into the buttons that actually
move your teeth so you basically have
braised the care is almost the same
except of this ridiculous level of oral
care that needs to happen because if you
put your clear retainer in and there's
any like food or anything in your mouth
like it'll just you know cause a cavity
because something is pressed up against
your teeth and gums you know what I'm
saying so you can only drink water with
them in anytime else you have to pop
them out to eat or drink anything other
than water anything other than water
then after that you have to brush your
teeth wash your teeth and then put your
Invisalign braces back in it click into
your buttons but my mind is sufficiently
blown right now I always thought that
this worm is just a little mouthpiece
that's why your fault it's because
that's how they market it to you smart
is like their clear retainers no
deception look like youtubers they're
people like here's me roasted Invisalign
I went from my consultation and they
showed me these clear braces I was going
to help and all of a sudden they were
like oh good we go submissive but sunny
mouth and I was like what buttons and
then they said like the buttons and now
these are my buttons and they smile and
their shoes look literal dots on my
teeth
yeah that's crazy did not know that yeah
they don't tell you that [ __ ] and they
get you in there and then they [ __ ]
rope you in with these clear braces just
getting you that clear braces on top of
your teeth what how did you eat the
buttons ah nasty meaning is it any of
all the good ones I have ever come with
Chipotle every worker has their own
personality and opinion on your serving
size oh that's so true though you ever
have someone that just gives way too
much of something that you don't want no
they always give me not in a price
always I'll like obviously I'm not
eating the sour cream but if someone's
like add like some sour cream I've seen
them just slop that until there's a
white bowl of slop I don't like girl I
get nasty in that ratio we thought we
thought you ought to do that give you
like this much carbs like these a little
scooper it gives you a tiny little bit
of protein while you're paying extra for
guac yeah
natty ice nobody buys us with a real ID
next okay good cause beer cause beer so
chill
claire's this is Stacey she's 19 it's
her first day she's gonna pierce your
ears for you sweetheart don't get the
gun oh [ __ ] Real Talk though when I got
my first holes in my ears like you know
I was like a kid I think it was like six
or seven and I went to like the Claire's
look in the mall and she drew the
markers on and she did the gun or
whatever and I remember her being pretty
young and I remember going home and
looking my Arabi like this was done did
it crooked
I imagine this price so like they're
still a little crooked
some like so common éclairs a happy
they're all so yummy it pierced my
cartilage with a gun damn it you
coordinated on Carmen how that [ __ ]
piercing gun here
no but you know what's worse Sally
Beauty just straight-up sells the gun
[ __ ] I plated itself a to go back yeah
daya oh you vegan how'd you like to be a
junk food week yeah yeah you have some
creative ways got some mac and cheese
what up you want a pizza I would love
some talking they are so good so [ __ ]
good it's so bad it's so good it's in a
good way though like it's so amazing but
like you really do not yeah
you want to eat junk food all the time
it's not junk but if you eat enough if
it's alright Lucroy we really nailed it
in on coconut that's just nasty we're
sorry coconuts go back coconut Lacroix
is not if you like coconut right and you
were my friend and that is a closet
attack don't text me although I did
drink it one time with my friend with
alcohol in it it was sort of like a you
know again tropical yeah and it wasn't
the worst part so dreams like by itself
is real nasty it's wrong Terron it's
just wrong it's like they asked their
employees to come up with flavors and
someone just [ __ ] up their deadline
and was like [ __ ] coconut
him only time I've ever heard of coconut
carbonated drink is in the office when
the warehouse workers win the water you
know and they go invest in all Japanese
energy drink that coconut penis flavored
energy drink and then do only if you
going off their chest up I'm pretty good
to take your time guys Britta
here have a passive-aggressive argument
with your roommate about drinking out of
it not filling it up oh my god that is
so [ __ ] true that is like I remember
like six things about college and that's
one of them like that it's so [ __ ]
funny that's really good
mmm Abbi no lol y'all think Jennifer
Anderson puts this [ __ ] on every base oh
my god it's not [ __ ] I'm sure it's a
very good product but we all in our
hearts of hearts we know Jennifer
Anderson not over here washing her face
with a V no you know what I'm saying
burner phone out Justin Theroux is
Julius is like an extreme justin theroux
Fionn no Jennifer Anderson has some
person with a diamond on a motorized
stick scraping off her skin cells every
single day like she's not washing your
face true skin goes off with a veto
she's not she's not going to CVS and
stocking up on oatmeal [ __ ] lotion
she's sucking up on people with diamonds
on their heads to scrape her face this
she's just learning some diamond [ __ ]
lotion let's be straight up all right
rainforest cafe mediocre food with
mediocre entertainment for you mediocre
evening beauty is your face I love the
attack at the end
oh you Nathan media of your family good
for real though like I know people love
the rainforest cafe and understand like
it's nostalgic it's fun it's whatever
but all like be be objective okay
all of it is mediocre it's like look out
for something it's mediocre your meals
mediocre it's not even that entertaining
okay
look you guys retain its mediocre unless
you're like before and with this case
it's [ __ ] magical but if you're a
dolt
come on all right
Charmian we've literally sent Big Daddy
and a family of them ran a person like
yourself I know on harm first of all why
are the Bears red I'm not sure either
way I just looked it up this is the
extra Tecton Charmin with a letter C
charming commercial Big Daddy is the
third that's a subway plan roll the tape
I gotta get to do we can't stay here
jerilyn favorite oh never get clean way
ahead of you Big Daddy what I want to
first understand wider read I also get
to pick doing entertainment baby people
to this video no understood like we want
that on the Sun so many vid Network apps
that we buy like what his salary yeah
y'all need I mean they play the same
[ __ ] ads so we see these ads a
hundred times and so we started to
recognize them and like we're number of
equates she just call him Big Daddy and
like she taught you I like it shouldn't
know she's your her like what is
happening here and they're red
uh I mean okay well and her whole
suitcase is filled up with one case of
totally but you brought nothing on your
vacation except toilet paper
did you see the moment when she pulls it
out the suitcase is empty after that
yeah it absolute sociopath it's true
speaking of terrible commercials on the
shows that we watch though this if you
if you look up Genaro Canelo
right he's a boxer yeah Canelo Alvarez
here just look up like be folder to
turkey Picatta commercial disc alone no
good copy nothing against Canelo nothing
is Sloane but these commercials are some
of the worst I have ever tried in subway
I just want to play the audio just
listen to this you have to look it up
and laugh yourself hey oh boy you know
[Music]
people there okay okay
no [ __ ] clue with that what anything
just was so cringe they're so good and
grim on every single good mercial break
it's okay it's cringe right but it makes
no sense like the acting is cringe but I
have no [ __ ] clue what they're trying
to tell me like what's the story here
what's the joke what's anything okay I
don't get it
it's Tecate and then you just really
speak and I've never heard Canelo Ebola
ever but that's fine but like he I
basically walked up he's in the boxing
gym right he's [ __ ] swinging it at me
and then and then he's like it's so lone
out of nowhere walks into his boxing gym
like in a private closed practice and
he's like be bold like if that happened
like get the [ __ ] out of here I'm
practicing I'm [ __ ] don't like to be
fair I feel like we have a high
tolerance of athletes when they take
commercial gay children be funny
no no like you can suck in world Kayla
oh god I actually like that's fine
Arriva they're in a movie like when
LeBron James was in trainwreck that Amy
Schumer movie they're like he's
fantastic like he's a lot of
personalities being funny that's the
exception for like if you're bad we're
like that's fine we don't care
fight to you here's one it's not it's
not that like he's bad hitting man and
anything good canal would have been
great it's like the idea and the
direction behind that commercial makes
no sense
he endings of Canelo I feel like if
there was anything with substance behind
that commercial it would have been
really it wasn't great but but
that that and of itself is whatever you
are Sylvester Stallone like yeah he's
not the best actor in the world but he
is an actor an expensive one can he be
he can't even make this good boy I think
the bottom line here is that my
commercial blows ass and I don't know
what they were even going for like it
what's their best-case scenario Big
Daddy Simon not Big Daddy yeah he did
way back 30 80
here you go Big Daddy family at least he
doesn't just [ __ ] surprise that at
least he doesn't just shake hands and
say big older women the commercials over
and you're left with like I have no
[ __ ] closure I don't even know what
happened
I don't know wider they're hugging I
don't know why there was a steak
involved why does he have a black eye
what's the backstory I don't know if
it's like everybody sitting in it in a
tub of ice and he's like canelo be bold
and then he looks over he's sitting in a
tub of ice and all of these beers just
pop up from the inside of the night
without any loss at first thought it
looks like boners it looks like ya don't
this is the sound of me cringing oh he
clenches hisses cringing at that -
anyways very more of it I'm done with
mine I'm done with mine - I'm almost
done with my wine eyeball there he bowed
their knee about that I told you I was
going to potentially do dinner so I'd
like to say shout out to me for keeping
my promise what are you going I'm just
people there this is fun I I found it as
finely as enjoyed this one do you have
any other one yeah no no dude did you
guys yeah they're not responding yeah
can they hear us
it's like a live audience all the time
well you don't come thank you guys for
hanging out for another episode this was
uh this was fun I appreciate it he
thought that'd be both you know bottom
line here ok Beebo they're on their feet
Oh LP a I you're ever in the motel
Marshall just like you you'll never do
worse than that one it's like Voltaire
but ball bear yeah sure
see Bob that I thank you guys for
hanging out appreciate you guys and as
you gain ten we'll see you next Monday
I'll take [ __ ] i doing
yeah oh sorry
[Music]